Hello Freak bitches like,
ah,
yeah,
you pulled the string back and then you let the Arrow fly.
Pretty straightforward,
like I think that's most people's idea of what archery is,
but then when you really pay attention to the technical aspects of all the
different stuff that's going on and all the different things you think about and
how you literally can not have anything on your mind other than all the
technique,
involve your foot placement,
your technique,
and standing,
your breathing where how you're drawing it back,
the position of your front shoulder,
the position of your rear elbow,
how you're pulling,
where it,
how,
what do you,
how do you respond after the arrows released?
There's so much going on that like when you put it all together like it,
it has.
It leaves no room for homework.
There's no room for relationship bullshit.
There's no room for taxes.
There's no room in there.
Man.
If you want to make a nice shot like that,
like I guarantee you,
if we could have a brain scan of your head the second you release that Arrow at
a hundred yards to go in that two inch gap,
there would be nothing in there other than what you did.
There would be no other.
No other cells would be fired up.
No,
no.
That's one thing.
And actually like yesterday when we were shooting there,
towards the end of the day,
you got to the point where you're almost.
Your mind was clear.
It's almost like for me,
you know,
your family came home,
like things are winding down.
You knew that like work was over and it was like right before dark.
And like for me,
I love shooting it at first light and it lasts light because it seems like
that's what I'm not really worried about.
Someone texting me or calling me.
I'm not worried about problem at home and I shoot with a clear mind and I am way
more efficient in my practice and it is a form of meditation.
I mean,
it's like you said,
it's an art and if you're clouded than you,
it will reflect that on the target.
I mean it's like if your arrows are in one spot,
then you know you have a single focus and it's almost like the more those arrows
are spread,
that's a representation of how many other thoughts and distractions you have
going in your mind.
I mean,
and I look at it that way when I shoot,
I'm trying to narrow everything down to just a movement and you look at good
golfers,
the ones that swing easy and it just literally looks like flow.
There's such good strikers and there's so much more efficient when you see
people that are trying to be robotic and,
and almost like hack something.
Then it's like too systematic.
You know,
you see someone like that does professional karate or something.
If they're in a forms competition,
if they're like real rigid going around.
It's just not what it's meant to be.
I mean it's supposed to be a dance.
It's supposed to be like literally a mental musical that's planned and if your
mind is clear,
then it's.
It's a form of meditation.
Is it?
Do you ever have male instincts to like buy a girl's neck when you're having sex
with her like that?
That kinda seems like you'd be somebody that would be like a neck bite or you'd
be really into it and just do not want you beaten off.
Thinking about how I felt,
so I will stop this conversation right here.
It's.
You know what?
It's different with different girls,
right?
With different girls.
You dated.
Some girls get choked.
They just do.
I hit all that.
When a girl tells me to slap them or choke them,
that's the worst.
I can't do it.
I'm not going to beat you up.
You're going to have to get that from somebody else.
You're going to have to call Ari.
Do you think the daddy thing?
There's something there.
When girls are like,
fuck me harder,
Daddy,
when it's the whole daddy thing,
do you think there's more to it?
It's a dirty,
dirty,
dirty.
They don't mean their dad.
They mean you.
They want you to be their daddy in that moment.
Not even like a father,
but like,
like the data that's given the Dick,
you know,
they don't even think it's like a different word.
It's a different use of the word Daddy,
you know?
It doesn't mean the same thing.
It's like when you call someone kept him sub captain.
You don't really think that guy has a boat,
but what if they're following?
Yeah,
I totally know.
But they say there's one girl says it as a kid though and she doesn't talk like
a kid in any other times except when she's having sex and she said that she
goes,
she regresses into like tolerable.
Yeah.
Well she's dating you.
Yeah,
some dark shit happened Bro.
but see,
I go deeper in it.
I was like,
yeah.
He like,
daddy stayed late for school
while you're fucking her seat leave for school.
I mean like I'm going to try to go down that path.
If she brings it up,
I'll see if she plays along.
If she plays along,
it's like fun.
It's like trying to learn more about this person that I'm fucking,
you know,
what's even more disturbing saying,
are you late for school because that means morning sex.
Like the dad doesn't even have the excuse of being drunk guy his coffee and
fucks his daughter.
That is God.
Yeah.
Just homework.
You need to find better people,
but you know,
you gotta work on yourself,
right?
I know.
Get your own shit in order and you'll attract people.
I don't make a noise.
I just don't know.
Breathe.
I slobbered in their hair and I
don't do anything.
I remember just being in awe and there was a bunch of other comedians that were
at the,
uh,
east side comedy club member,
east side in Long Island.
Richard Mydomain.
Yep.
Richard Miller.
Vini.
Me and Kevin James.
We're sitting around after the show and we're shaking.
Her head were like,
God damn,
he's good.
God dammit.
He apparently did two different hours on a Friday night.
He did two shows in eight and a 10 to two completely different hours,
completely top to bottom.
And they were like,
both of them were slaughtering his,
just a destroyer,
brilliant writer.
I remember feeling like what he,
he could take premises that you didn't think there was anything there and you
can turn them into like one of your favorite bits,
like you did a premise about buying a corvette and the guy trying to talk them
into all sorts of stuff in the corvette.
And I remember thinking while he was doing this.
Wow,
how is this Guy gonna make this funny?
Yeah.
It's talking about buying an expensive sports car and he's going to figure out
how to make this funny number.
The ref thing.
He did.
I had a bunch of the football,
well,
you know,
we have problems seminar.
And it really was because of him and let's say.
And they couldn't it because he's dead now.
But what happened was we were getting different things at the same time,
you know,
like different competitive with each other.
Well he was competitive with me and I think because people pitted us against
each other purely because we're short Italians.
Well,
I'm a short Italian as well,
but you've never been anything but supportive.
Nice.
Joseph,
but I mean,
not one time I said to him,
because somebody was struggling.
I said,
why don't we go out on the road together?
Oh yeah,
we'll fill up theaters.
And he goes,
why would I want to do that?
I said,
I don't know.
Make money to have fun.
You know,
he didn't understand the concept.
Yeah.
He said to me one time,
he goes,
Montreal comedy festival.
You think I should go there?
I said,
go with the idea that you're going to meet beautiful girls.
Go to great restaurants and if you happen to get a deal,
you do,
but have fun.
And he was fun.
He looked at me like,
what?
What do you mean for fun?
This isn't fun.
This just,
he was tortured.
Wow.
He never enjoyed it,
you know?
That's the saddest part of it.
He was seeing never knew how good he was or he never enjoyed how good he was.
I first met him in Montreal.
Yeah.
I first met him in like,
well,
isn't that where I met you for?
Yup.
I met him in 94 just so we were both passing each other and in the front doors
just said,
hi,
hey man,
nice to meet you,
blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
What shows you doing that kind of thing.
Just,
you know,
and it seemed to me like he just was a,
just a brilliant,
brilliant mind thinking,
but just always its own had maybe almost too much.
I saw him on a plane.
I was getting.
I was flying back.
Remember they had three cabins and the American knows in first class he was in
coach with Lenny.
Lenny Clarke.
No,
law clerk.
Linny Africanus.
Lenny Shoultz.
Crazy one.
No,
not that crazy land.
More pigs.
More Shit.
Somebody fucking Lenny's in common.
But what are lenny,
you,
Dave Hawthorne's friend.
You wouldn't know them.
Okay.
But anyway,
uh,
he spent like,
I walked back to say hi.
And he goes,
you know,
I usually play by myself.
I'm compliant him.
I said,
it's okay.
I went,
it's all right.
I didn't fly.
ABC flew me and he didn't like that either.
I'm thinking,
I didn't know.
Do I have to rub it in and then I probably said to him,
rich,
what do you want me to do?
You want my cookie?
I'm just in first class.
Not a big fucking deal.
You guys are so Italian.
That's such an attack.
My is.
Doesn't even have the good Salami over there.
Fucking Salamis.
Get tonight treads.